live now to Prime Minister Boris
Johnson's constituency in the west of
London where the count is about to begin
he has a slim majority of just over five
thousand votes so it's not a given that
the Prime Minister is going to secure
his seat but let's listen independent 69
Hugh's David Stephen commonly known as
Lord Buckethead the official monster
raving loony party 125 Burke Norma
independent 22 Courtney Jeffrey Dennis
UK Independence Party 283 Humphreys Jo
Ann alone Liberal Democrats to stock
brexit 3026 Johnson Alexander Boras turf
Ethel commonly known as Boris Johnson
the Conservative Party candidate 25,000
[Applause]
25350 one Kia mark Alyn Green Party 1090
[Music]
Milani Ali Riza Labour Party 18140 one
[Applause]
Smith Robert Jr commonly known as Bobby
Elmo Smith eight Tobin William John five
uh ting Alfie John independent 44 yogin
Stein yes commonly known as yes
interplanetary time Lloyd yogin Stein 23
the number of rejected ballot papers was
93 and I hereby declare that the said
Boris Johnson is duly elected to your
attorney officer good morning everybody
good morning ladies and gentlemen thank
you all very much learning it's like a
water I don't want to tempt fate
because clearly lots of results are
still coming in and we're still only
dealing with projections but at this
stage it does look as though this one
nation Conservative government has been
given a powerful new mandate to get
grexit done and not just you get brexit
done but to unite this country and to
take it forward and to focus on the
priorities of the British people and
above all on the NHS and yes we will
recruit 50,000 more nurses and 6,000
more jeebies and we will build 40 new
hospitals and I am proud to say that one
of the across the country and one of
those hospitals will be right here in
Uxbridge and South riesling and I am
grateful I am grateful once again to the
people of oxygen sighs Ruislip for
returning me to serve you it is an ABS
lewd privilege to do this job and to
work for you and I thank once again the
the police the council everybody who's
worked so hard all night to count for us
the returning officers I thank my fellow
candidates in all their glory lord
Buckethead and others Elmo and others
forgive me if I if I don't if I don't
identify them all but I bubble I want to
thank I want to thank the people of this
country for turning out to vote in a
December election that we didn't want to
call but which I think has turned out to
be a historic election that gives us now
in this new government the chance to
respect the democratic will of the
British people to change this country
for the better and to unleash the
potential of the entire people of this
country and that is what we will now do
and if we are lucky enough to be
returned as the polls as the exit polls
seem to suggest then that work will
begin tomorrow thank you all very much
rather I should say not tomorrow today
thank you all very much thank you so
Boris Johnson the the Prime Minister and
leader of the Conservative Party more
than doubling his majority in his own
constituency a vote emphatically in
favor of his get Brax it done message a
simple message that seems at this point
to have resonated around the country
because the Conservative Party are
predicted to get a landslide victory of
majority of something like that
86 seats in a 650 seat Parliament which
of course will allow Boris Johnson in
the Conservative Party to do pretty much
what they like first things first of
course will be brexit Jonah Hall is a
correspondent covering all of this and
Jonah interesting that Boris Johnson
with his magnificent new majority in his
constituency and spent quite a bit of
time trying to pivot and deal with the
issue of domestic public services which
of course many people have accused him
of neglect
in favor of the brexit message yes
absolutely he was drawn into that debate
very much wasn't he by the Labor Party
and Terry Corbin who were keen to
refocus attention away from brexit that
didn't work for labour Boris Johnson was
criticized for not spending enough time
in his own constituency there were
concerns that he might lose his own seat
that would have been pretty
extraordinary but there you saw him
capping what has been an extraordinary
night for the Conservative Party by
winning and winning handsomely in
Oxbridge and South Ruislip a historic
election he said that we didn't want to
call a chance to respect respect the
democratic will of the people let me
bring in Emma Hayward our reporter she's
standing by in the constituency she was
there listening to Boris Johnston Emma
relief I imagine all round and the
celebrations I think will very shortly
get underway weren't they yeah decisive
win for Boris Johnson here he is still
up on the stage listening to the other
candidates they're a decisive one as I
say twenty-five thousand three hundred
and fifty one votes the nearest
candidate the Labour candidate who many
thought might even beat Boris Johnson
got 18,000 141 votes and in his
acceptance speech Forrest Johnson said
that the result gave him the greatest
powerful mandate to get brexit done he
talked about new hospitals but he also
said this result this result this
natural result would unleash the entire
potential of the country for exit has
dominated this election from the from
the get-go it's dominated his politics
here for the past three and a half years
and Boris fancies message to get by
stunned to finally get it over the line
seems to have really resonated with
voters as the results show tonight and
of course he was up against a pretty
determined remain alliance with a strong
challenge from a young Labour Party
candidate so much for the whole idea of
tactical voting Emma yes
tactical voting was seen as a big issue
in this election two million I think
though was talked about as the bigger of
people who were going to
tactically in different seats as they
would normally do people voting in
different ways this time that has I
think has been one of the defining
things of tonight people who would
normally vote labor in those labor
heartlands whose families have voted for
generations for labor have turned Tory
and it was unthinkable and places like
working turn it is such a surprise that
well it's not so much of a surprise but
it is such a turn around in places like
that for people to turn their backs on
labor and vote conservative because it
goes against the grain in those kind of
places and ever not just a big loss for
labour tonight but Joe Swinson we're
hearing in eastern Barton Shire has lost
her seat as well the Liberal Democrat
leader so bad news for opposition
parties all except of course the
Scottish National Party in Scotland but
really I mean an absolutely resounding
victory for the Conservatives you're
right there watching them you've been
with their activists in that
constituency seat they must be
absolutely delighted I think they'll be
absolutely thrilled I was talking to a
couple of them earlier who said they had
every faith that Boris Johnson would win
here even if it was by one vote that he
would gain a majority and I think that
has been felt throughout the country
actually I think that the size of the
vote tonight has surprised many because
the polls just didn't suggest that it
would be that great a loss for labour
for Jeremy Corbyn has said heavily that
he won't campaign again in a general
election and labour obviously now will
probably have to do some soul-searching
to try to win back those labour
heartlands that was so important to them
up until tonight okay Emma thanks we'll
leave it there for the moment